i'm treating you like a responsible
human being like responsible for not
shutting down traffic like responsible
for not telling lies
about the police the democratic party
has decided to foment racial
polarization for purposes of electoral
victory
enough of this crap already meanwhile as
though the economy were not already
slowing
as though we didn't already have enough
crises on our hands the
the baton administration is doing an
unbelievable job of manufacturing crisis
pretty much everywhere at home and
abroad we'll start with at home and then
we'll get to abroad because it really is
fairly incredible how they've somehow
manufactured an economic crisis
where there really ought not be one
they're manufacturing a coveted crisis
where the coveted crisis
is on the wane and essentially done in a
bunch of states
and they continue to foment social panic
with regard to race relations in the
united states
so the black lives matter movement
continues to
create issues in cities across the
country the latest example comes
courtesy
of plano texas so plano is about as red
in the area as it is possible to find
plano is like 65 35 republican democrat
it may be higher than that
hey black lives matter took over an
intersection anyway and the cops decided
instead of clearing the intersection
they were just going to allow black
lives matter to take over the
intersection and stop traffic which is
nuts enough of this crap already okay
you can get a license to protest you get
a license to shut down streets but if
you just decide to show up in the middle
of the street
and shut down traffic then everybody has
a right to be pissed at you one driver
got out of his car the police decided
that he was the problem not the people
who were holding up the traffic
this guy was ticked off he's you know
and and the cops show up
people are screaming at him and um
people are flipping him off what are the
cops doing nothing the cops are just
standing there doing nothing
that's not the cops fault that's not the
cops fault right the cops have been told
presumably by their political higher-ups
to not stop this sort of nonsense it's
an absurdity
now this sort of of social division in
the country is simply not a good thing
and the fact that the police have been
told to stand down in the face of this
sort of stuff
is really really bad but again this is
all part and parcel of the giant's
equity push
being put forward by the biden
administration
it's part of the continuing
fragmentation of american
life on the basis of race michelle obama
who of all the people in
the united states should be pretty
grateful
for how great the united states has been
to her i feel this way about anybody
who's in a position of high power i'm
very very grateful
to the united states for all the
opportunities that i've had michelle
obama who went to princeton university
and grew up in a two-parent family
and became a highfalutin lawyer and
earned a big salary
and married the president of the united
states you know she really
it seems should be pretty grateful for
the fact
that the that this country's been good
to her
but she has not been grateful for that
for quite a while i mean you'll recall
back in 2008 michelle obama suggested
openly that the first time that she had
been that she had been
grateful for the country or the first
time that she'd been proud of the
country rather
is when her husband was nominated for
the presidency that's the first time in
her life which is pretty amazing
considering again she went to princeton
university well now michelle obama and
president obama are speaking out
a lot about reyes in an excerpt of an
interview that's going to be released
later today with gayle king of cbs this
morning
michelle obama revealed her fears that
the couple's daughters malia and sasha
could call
could fall victim to racist aggression
as they go about their everyday lives
she said every time they get in a car by
themselves i worry about what assumption
is being made by somebody who doesn't
know everything about them
maybe they're playing their music a
little loud maybe somebody sees the back
of their head and makes an assumption
i like so many parents of black kids the
innocent act of getting a license put
fears in our hearts again this is just
rooted in non-data the notion that
young black women are being gunned down
by the cops for the
crime of being black is insane that is
not backed by data
but she's pushing it anyway because the
democratic party has decided to foment
racial polarization for purposes of
electoral victory
in the same interview michelle praised
blm she said they're taking to the
streets because they have to do they
have to though
you know those two billion dollar riots
last year was that a thing that had to
happen they're trying to have people
understand that we're real folks
oh we get that you're real folks and i'm
treating you like a responsible human
being
like any other responsible human being
you know
like responsible for not shutting down
traffic like responsible for not telling
lies
about the police the the bigotry of low
expectations
exists and it is quite prevalent on the
american left
and of course the obamas are earning
strange new respect from the same left
that had started to move away from them
over all of this sort of stuff don lemon
doing the same thing over on cnn he says
that tim scott
the senator from south carolina who has
said america's not a racist country says
well you know tim scott's not an
oreo which is a racial slur meaning
black on the outside white on the inside
he's not an oreo
he just you know doesn't care about
black folks so basically he's an oreo
according to don lemon obviously you
don't need
the name calling and any time you call
someone a name anytime you
do that you don't want to become them so
you stoop to their level
you give your your competitors
ammunition
uh and you give them a talking point and
you become them
i think that it is damaging to
democrats if they're trying to do that
and it gives republicans talking points
tim scott should be held accountable for
what he's doing
and if he is voting against the interest
of his own people
so don't stop calling him names also
he's voting against the interests of his
own people
well well done don lemon the fomenting
of racial polarization in a country that
as of 2008
was at the height of a trajectory toward
being non-racist
is impressive how we've reversed that
over the clock over the course of the
last decade and a half or so
pretty amazing how we reverse that so
quickly the battle for the culture is
heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe
ring that bell because you're not going
to want to miss a single moment